- What?
Whose is that?
- Yours?
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Can I sit in it?
No.
For real?
- For real.
I've never seen you cry like this.
I'm here with Justin Bieber
today and today we're gonna see
what do people think about Justin Bieber?
- Oh my God, love him, but
Yummy is just like, not it.
It's not that good.
- It's not it!
- Oh my God!
- It's not it?
- Here's 25 grand.
- Oh!
- What?
(laughs)
- David!
- [David] My hands shaking, take it quick.
- Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
- To say our first guest is
a social media sensation,
well, that really just doesn't cut it.
I'm actually really excited
about this interview
and I take it seriously because
David Dobrik is someone who,
I feel, is a very unique and
important person in this world.
He is someone who has a very loud voice
and a very big platform.
And I'm really excited
to talk to him because
what he does in this world is meaningful.
And as someone who
loves joy
and silliness
and all of those things, the
other side of me is someone who
really cares about taking care of people
and showing the
possibilities in the world.
And so when I think of David
Dobrik, I get really excited
because it isn't talk.
It's all really happening in his world
and we're all watching it.
So without further ado, ladies
and gentlemen, David Dobrik.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
- Hi.
- How are you?
That was brutally nice.
It seems like we paid
you off to say all that.
That was like a paragraph.
Usually I get here's
YouTuber, David Dobrik,
but that was awesome, thank you.
- No, no no.
You are anything but just a YouTuber.
You are someone who,
first of all, your numbers.
I mean eight billion views and,
you know, 20 million followers
is obviously so impressive.
You know, I think back to
like Candid Camera and I think
about the history of the
medium of how you reach people
while being authentically who you are.
Was there always a time
where you thought you wanted
to have this be this,
sort of like, feel good,
philanthropic, like surprise
people, pay mortgages,
like donate cars.
When did you sort of think like
Oprah and Jackass would bake
a really potent combination
with a dash of brunt?
- That's funny.
- When did I first?
I don't know, I was a big fan growing up.
I was a big fan of
military surprise videos.
Like I loved when soldiers
would come home from like
these long tours and they'd
surprise their families,
and I was like, I'm such
a sucker for reactions.
Like whether someone's
reacting like they're terrified
or they're scared or they're super happy.
Like I love it all.
So when I got the chance
to surprise people
in a positive way rather
than like scare 'em
with like a spider or some
kind of an animal, that's what,
like, I wanted to lean towards.
It's the most selfish
feeling to surprise others
with people, because like
the joy you get from them
being happy, is just like
it pays it back tenfold.
Like it's the best.
- And I think some people,
unfortunately, have a little bit
of a gotcha.
I'm not a big fan of that.
And when I watch your stuff,
there is such a goodness there.
There is,
- Thanks
- there is this sweetness, this kindness,
this joy where you do
really get off at watching
people's reactions,
but it's based in good.
- I always say that, like
the moments that you've seen
my videos are very much the real moments
that I'm experiencing in real life too.
And that's why I like
making videos on YouTube
is because it's such an intimate
thing and you can have such
an intimate interaction with
strangers and you can have like
that actual moment like when you're like,
there was a time we
surprised this DACA girl.
I think it was with like
$25,000, I'm not sure.
But like, it was just me
and her and her friends
sitting in, like, in her Jeep.
And like, it feels all so real.
And like being able to capture that moment
and having that forever is like the best.
- And you are DACA.
You are a dreamer.
- Right, yeah.
- So is that personal in that moment?
- Yeah, it was really
funny 'cause I was in Texas
and this kid walks up to me and he goes,
my girlfriend's DACA, just like you.
I am too.
She works two jobs.
She has a kid.
She's 19 years old.
And then we went to go meet
up with her and her two
other friends were there,
and they were also all DACA.
So it was like four or five
of us sitting in this car.
And it was like so cool
because it was just a car full
of these illegals, including me. (laughs)
And we're just like
laughing and like, you know,
making light of our situation.
And that was like the coolest
thing, like to to be able
to share a moment with
people like that, was like
really, really awesome.
- Something that I really
appreciated, and you just seem
so genuine to me and not
ego-driven and so much more
joy-driven, but when you
stopped doing your videos,
was there sort of a, I
need to just stop a moment.
I don't know, what was it for you?
- I think there's also this
thing with specifically people
in social media is it moves so quickly
and you're your own boss, so
you're pumping out content
like as fast as you can.
And I think it's a
really easy to get like,
so like infatuated with like
the instant gratification of it
and like, how quickly you can
make stuff and you just get
like addicted to like making
videos and making content.
And I remember when I stopped,
it was like very much like
I was like entering civilization again.
It was, I don't know how to explain it.
It sounds so bizarre, but
it was like, I wasn't there.
And I was like never present for like
the last three, four years.
I was just like in
this, like, in this zone
of go, go go, and I know
it sounds ridiculous.
And I know people are at home
like, he makes YouTube videos.
Why is that?
But, that's what it felt like.
- That's the thing, you don't
just make YouTube videos.
- I appreciate that.
- And I think
that, I think you have a
big civil responsibility
on your hands because so
many people are watching you.
And when you take a pause, I
think you are saying it is okay
for all of us to take off the helmet,
- Aw, thanks.
- and stop for a minute.
- It's really important
just to hit refresh
on the whole thing and just
take a moment and be like,
okay, this is what I was doing.
This is what I need to change.
And like you know, let me
get back to being a human
for a little bit.
- You're very enthusiastic and
like charming and excitable
and all of those things.
And believe me, I've been
thinking about this lately
because I have my dark moments.
Do you have dark moments?
'Cause you're so
excitable out there.
- 100 %.
Like when the cameras are off,
I am a little dark and like,
I am hard on myself and
I'm not Miss Mary Sunshine.
Like when the cameras go off,
are you intense about your work?
Like, do you have a different
personality that comes up
a little bit?
- I'm so, so hard on myself.
Yeah, but yeah, I think
that comes with anybody
that wants, you know,
that is an entertainer.
I think there are definitely dark moments,
but those aren't the moments
that you want other people
to see for, you know, a number of reasons.
But that doesn't take
away the authenticity
of the real moments that
you're actually drawing.
It's not like, you know,
it's not like we come on here
and we like put on this like
fake front where we're like,
we're happy, but really
behind closed doors
where we're miserable.
I still think that I'm, you
know, for the most part,
a super, super happy person,
but there are definitely
moments where I'm like, ah,
nothing's going my way right now.
- So we're both crazy, but
we're both really happy.
And we both really care about what we do.
I like that you're
hitting so many cylinders.
You have a perfume.
- Yeah, I have a perfume.
I honestly, if I'm
being completely honest,
why I did the perfume, other
than the fact that I like
really, really love it, I've
just been such a big fan
of perfume commercials and
commercials in general.
And quite specifically,
there's a Natalie Portman
Dior commercial,
- Of course.
- that I'm like obsessed with.
- Yeah.
I love Natalie Portman to death.
So I'm always wanting to make
like a commercial on my own.
So I got to make a little
commercial for my perfume,
which I was really excited about.
And I'm just like a big fan of the scent.
- By the way, I am so excited for Dispo.
Are you kidding?
That is
- A what?
- going to be huge.
- Oh thanks, that means a lot.
So now we're doing this Dispo
thing and it's slowly going
to turn into, sort of like
a social media where you can
share those pictures with
other people that I used to go
to like some parties at my
friend's house and they would
put disposable cameras
all around the house.
And instead of everyone
Instagramming all night
and waiting to get the
right shot and being like,
wait, wait, move here, move here,
they would just take
quick disposable pictures
and it literally never ruined a moment.
Like, I don't know.
I'm really excited for
that to make it work.
- You are just amazing.
I was so excited to talk to you,
really and truly.
I marvel at what you do.
- I was so excited
to talk to you.
I really appreciate all
those words and I don't know.
I'm sure you know by now,
but I'm the biggest fan
of 50 First Dates.
- I love that, but your friend,
Jason, doesn't agree, right?
- No, no.
So I was tryin' to tell him,
I was like 50 First Dates
is in the top 10 best movies of all time.
And he just didn't understand it. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
- Well, actually, we're
gonna be right back
with a surprise for Jason, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
We have Jason on Zoom
and I'm gonna get him
to talk a little crap
about 50 First Dates,
and then you can appear
and set him straight.
- I will see you in two minutes.
We'll be right back.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)